nikki manion of et canada go ahead
well congratulations first off
um
how does it feel to not only win this
but also um you know what there's some
competition with your fellow coasters
who are also nominated you have to buy
them dinner now
yeah to buy them dinner forever
yeah especially kieran culkin no no no
it's it's lovely
it sort of takes the um
it takes any weird
pressure away when it's lots of you from
the same
show in a category i think and
especially one we're very
you know we're quite a close company
so it's really nice it's really nice and
it's an ensemble piece as well so it
feels a bit weird but it's it's it's a
very nice thing
our next question comes from joy paris
of rich girl network tv
congratulations great show thank you
my question to you would be um it's such
a racial can you share with me any scene
or part of the project that was most
challenging for you and how did you go
past that
uh nothing was really challenging not to
say that you know there's always
challenges it's just fun
the scripts are so um
they're so interesting and funny and
full of stuff uh that i i think i just i
relish it all rather than
you know i'm so there are some scenes
which is you know quite daunting to play
but you know
mostly it's really good fun especially
like throwing water bottles at nicholas
braun and you know stuff like that
yeah great thanks so much
our next question comes from sharon
carpenter of bbc
hi matthew congratulations um i want to
know how much fun is it to play tom and
how cool is it to be a part of a show
that so many people love so much 25
nominations
i know it's very a mere 25. no it's
really lovely it's really gratifying
that um
people loved the show that sort of
landed in the culture so well it took a
while to get going i think and then um
yeah no it's really it's really nice and
it's just a hoot we get these scripts
come in
you know
every every month or so and the new
episode comes in and it's just thrilling
uh because none of us really know what's
going to happen
and the writing is so good
and so interesting and
so it's a sort of it's exciting to see
where the characters go it's great
this is our final zoom question if
anyone in the room has a question please
raise your hand and this question comes
from larry fink
[Music]
hi matthew congratulations
thank you um you know what does it mean
what does it mean for you to
to win this semi and
you know talk about
the incredible family drama on
succession i've never seen anything
quite like it
yeah it's quite um shakespearean isn't
it it's quite greek it's those those big
epic family struggles
that are sort of the yeah they're
perennial um
well first of all to answer the first
part of the question it means an awful
lot to win this it's really it's a real
privilege and honor to be in the show
and then to be
um to get this it's just very it's very
flattering it's very nice indeed um
yeah i just i just really love the job
it's really good fun go it doesn't feel
like going to work
our next question comes from inside the
room
from usa today
hi congratulations um thank you you said
this is a bonkers gift this role can you
talk to me about how it's changed your
life and i need to ask how you're going
to celebrate tonight
[Laughter]
uh i don't know how i'm going to
celebrate uh
yeah that will it'll all reveal itself
it is um
but it'll be very nice
it's a yeah uh
it's it is a gift of a part because it's
just um
it's very different
i think as an actor you want to
play parts you haven't played before or
you know
previously and so this is a big stretch
from some previous parts i've played
tend to play a lot of buttoned up
englishmen sometimes in period costume
and so to play you know
a midwestern
guy
who one critic described as a human
grease stain
is uh is really really good fun and
really good therapy as well i get to do
things which
are sort of really embarrassing
in the safety of a set so it's good yeah
it's good
our next question comes from lynette
rice with deadline hi hi hey ben so the
final moment when we see you really
stick it to siobhan uh i'm curious what
the reaction was during your hiatus from
friends family whoever like yeah
and in the new season do you pick it up
almost immediately or where will we see
you then
uh the reaction was quite i got a lot of
um
my favorite uh reaction was it was a
a picture message from my agent who was
just like that
that was what it was and some other
friends it was just faces like what
um but it's a good ending and it sort of
sets up it sets up the you know the
story going forward
um
and i forgot the second part of your
question
oh uh i think we pick it up a little bit
after this little little bit of time has
elapsed the dust has sort of settled
a little bit not very much though
our final question comes from mike
schneider with variety
so matthew now that uh we've discovered
that tom's a little diabolical do you
think that's going to change how people
see the characters see how you play the
character or
is there a different edge to him now in
the new season
uh i don't know i don't know what the
diabolicals
were maybe a bit strong i think he was
just
i don't know i think
he certainly doesn't think he's
diabolical i think he thinks he's
probably just looking out for himself
and he's
you could argue that he's really
suffered at the hands of
his
you know his brothers-in-law and his
wife
and he's terrified of his father-in-law
and he was just sort of looking after
number one and so um
yeah i'm scared of i'm scared of um
giving away spoilers if i go on but it's
uh yeah it's nicely to heat up the
season four
yeah
was our final question for matthew
thanks so much
[Applause]